Never lie to an x-ray technician.
They can see right through you.
Hey everyone, Julia here for Dnews.
Most of us have gotten an x-ray at some point.
At the dentist or when we break a bone.
But I always had to wear an uncomfortable
heavy lead apron.
So that makes me wonder… are they safe?
And how the hell can they see through me?
X-rays are just another form of electromagnetic
energy which is a long spectrum.
Visible light, what we can see, just makes
a tiny part of it.
On one end are radio waves on the other gamma
rays.
X-rays has waves that have a higher energy
and are a little longer than gamma rays but
a little shorter than visible light.
We can’t see ‘em but they can sure see
through us.
They were discovered in 1895 when a German
scientist was experimenting with passing electrical
currents through gas in tubes.
These tend to light up when hit with electrons,
so Wilhelm Conrad Röntgen, covered one of
his tubes up with a box.
but he noticed something strange, an object
nearby glowed.
He assumed that some type of energy was getting
through the box.
But he didn’t know what kind of energy so
he called it x.
He found that it passed easily through some
objects, like our soft tissues.
But not through others like our bones or especially
lead.
He produced the first image of an x-ray by
taking a radiograph of his wife’s hand in
1895.
It was heralded as a medical miracle.
Suddenly the new technology took off.
Everyone was using it to find breaks in bones
or bullets lodged in bodies.
But soon people noticed some problems.
Early x-ray techs started have skin problems
on their hands.
The skin would be dry and scaly, or they’d
get burns and their hair would fall out.
After a while, the damage would be so severe
they’d have to amputate fingers, hands,
sometimes whole arms.
Dozens of people died from radiation exposure.
But no one really seemed to take heed.
People used x-rays for removing unwanted facial
hair or for shoe fittings.
Not surprisingly people got sick.
Women who got x-ray treatment to remove hair
wound up with dry, scaly, skin, enlarged blood
vessels, and finally developing a skin cancer.
But is it safe now?
Well we certainly learned our lesson from
those early days!
They’re still considered a carcinogen by
the World Health Organization.
And one study published in the journal Cancer
found a link for a slight increased risk for
certain brain cancers and frequent dental
x-rays.
Another study published in the journal Lancet
found an up to 6% risk of cancer from diagnostic
x-rays.
But we’ve come along way.
Medical x-rays in the 50s used almost 100x
the radiation now considered acceptable.
Basically the amount of radiation during an
x-ray is pretty small.
According to the FDA, an x-ray of your bones
in your hands or feet is pretty comparable
to a day’s worth of natural background radiation.
But other procedures have different levels
of exposure.
There are enormous benefits to x-rays, the
pros by far outweigh the cons.
They’re an incredible diagnostic tool.
They find bone breaks, blood clots, tumors,
and many many more things you really want
to know about without invasive exploratory
surgery.
But don’t be afraid to ask questions, make
sure it’s medically necessary and ask to
wear the protective shields, they’re like
a lead apron or neck guard.
Since radiation is cummulative over the course
of your life, keep track of your x-ray history
and make sure your medical professional knows.
X-Rays help catch far more cases of cancer
than they cause.
Speaking of catching cancer, it seems South
Korea is over diagnosing cancer.
To find out why, check out this great video
from my buddy Evan over at Seeker Daily.
And don’t forget to subscribe to that channel,
they’ve got great videos for the adventurer
in all of us.
Alright guys, got any questions about other
medical mysteries?